Ami's 2017 what you didn't see on TV
plus were with Jackie Chan and the cast
of the lego ninjago movie hi friends and
welcome to this special Emmys edition of
The Daily denne
I'm calling it the daily Demi i'm danny
director and i'm tired I was on the red
carpet at the 69th annual Emmy Awards
where I ditched my signature denim
jacket for a tuxedo jacket to bring you
guys along for TV's biggest night
[Music]
it's the Emmys red-carpet I'll give you
guys an exclusive inside look at what
it's really like
very exciting don't you think we're all
right we are here at our position on the
Emmys red carpet now I know you guys are
used to seeing me in front of the camera
from Mosul producer and today I am
pulling double-duty I am feel producing
the one and only Lauren Zima today so
what are we asking the stars today what
do go on though here's the thing we want
another red carpet secrets so we're
gonna ask what's your red carpet ritual
what do you have to do before you get an
award show carpet what do you always do
before hitting the red carpet I
definitely have a cocktail take a lot of
photos of the look and do different
angles and a different lighting today I
had some Rose a because it's early in
the day if it's later I'll have some
tequila what are your secrets to
attacking the red carpet I watched what
Gwen Stefani does on a red carpet we try
to copy her what's one thing you do to
celebrate when it's over I drink
martinis oh my god but every day two
always friends yeah beautiful let me
show you guys these are all of our
questions 45 pages I I'm looking at head
so she's talking to someone I'm looking
past her to see who's coming up it's a
question we do a quick regroup or I go
on Instagram literally and find out
what's going on with them honestly how
many hours would you estimate goes into
researching before a show like Danny I
started since I was aged 10 and it's
been a really long time coming that was
so so much fun the novelty has not worn
out for me I love that red carpet but
for a lot of stars the party went well
into the night and not just for the
folks 21 and over
check out Billy Bobby Brown and the cast
of stranger things getting into a dance
battle with this is us star
Lonnie Chavis at Netflix's afterparty
[Music]
I see you Bonnie
all right now his co-star sterling came
Brown one lead actor in a drama for
plain adult Randle his TV mom Mandy
Moore shared this sweet moment calling
him a master performer and an even
better friend this is us was one of my
favorite shows this year but the show I
watched every Sunday religiously was big
little lies Nicole Kidman was a double
Emmy winner last night
her co-star Reese Witherspoon also
snagged her trophy as executive producer
of the show and shared this sweet shot
of the two of them after they won Reese
is crying and she really did not let up
on the emotions even when we caught up
with her at the HBO party what's the
first thing you're gonna do when you get
inside to celebrate I just hug my kids
my dogs take off the shoes have a
cocktail or two just enjoy it let it all
sink in it's a really exciting moment
but it's overwhelming I was gonna say is
it overwhelming you feel I feel like I
look at you you're kind of trying to
still wrap your head around the fact
that you may see for sure it's exciting
because yeah I just didn't expect any of
this and it's really emotional for me we
have more with Reese and the big little
lies cast backstage at the Emmys they
are still teasing a season two that's
over at ET online.com all right I was a
busy man this weekend because it was not
only the Emmys but I was also at the
premiere of the lego ninjago movie and
let me tell you if there is one reason
to be working on a Saturday at 10:00
a.m. it's Jackie Chan who confirmed to
me that a rush hour 4 is in the works
Raja will probably
rush hour report when it here next year
next yeah Alex said are you to reunite
with your co-stars oh good exciting you
know those kind of movie I know the
audio and they like it do you like it I
make it but we put a good message you're
inside yeah I know Chris Tucker misses
you Christopher Chris Tucker you you you
don't want to see me I forget you come
on buddy
he misses you man I just met Jackie Chan
kind of freaking out about that but I
want to find out from the cast
what would their Lego minifigs look like
what doesn't Olivia Munn Lego look like
you probably have bread in one hand and
and a ponytail and sneakers and and
probably makeup on her clothes probably
not far off from Garmadon I mean minus
the helmet right that's pretty much an
all black on black on some most of the
time cool hair yeah maybe a biker jacket
or big bushy gray eyebrows it's not that
far off from Nia in everyday clothes
it's like yes I wear a lot of stripes
leather jacket jeans he's very insecure
and he thinks a lot about what t-shirt
he's gonna wear okay hard about your
t-shirt on I I don't ever think I'm
making the right decision with my lego
minifigure would deadly have a big head
on account of my hair big brows and if
I'm not wearing a button-up probably
Beyonce t-shirt alright we'll have more
from my interviews with the lego ninjago
cask later this week the movie hits
theaters on September 22nd until then be
sure to watch ET tonight and head over
to our website ET online.com there is so
much more from the Emmys red carpet
backstage and after parties plus all the
fashion we're still unpacking it all and
I'm about to unpack my sleeping bag and
take a nap in the office I'll see you
guys tomorrow